INJURY.
DAVID McDONOUGH HAS  HAVE MULTI
TRYING TO CONTAIN IT THERE,
PULLED UP BY TAMPA BAY WAS BROK
LIGHTNING.
>> GET YOURSELF IN THE RIGHT
STATS SHOW THAT YOU
END UP BEING ON THE SHORT SIDE
OF
BACK, THE OTHER WAY, HELD TO
THE LINE, BY JOSEPH.
AND
>>NET WHILE HE DANCES AROUND
AND WILL MAKE IT BACK TO THE
LINE, THAT PASS GETS AWAY.
>>NOR, HIGH-STICKING.
BROUGHT DOWN BY MIKHAIL
WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS LIKE THAT IN
THE LINEUP, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THINGS A
THATCHER DIS TAKEN UP HIGH, BUT
BIG BULLET THERE, THEY ARE
STILL INSIDE THE LINE.WITH VANCO
HE GETS THE PASS, HE WAS THERE,
HE DIDN'T OVERCOMMIT.
HE
LINE.
>>
ICE, HE GOES RIGHT BACK TO THE
OTHER END OF THE ICE, AND WATCH
AND A CHANCE, WHAT A CHANCE
FOR THE BEST SHOT. THAT WILL PR
DO